everyone's president Ibrahim raisi has
arrived in Indonesia hoping to boost
economic ties he'll meet president Joko
Widodo and the two are set to sign a
preferential Trade Agreement Iran is
currently facing tough economic
sanctions from the U.S over its nuclear
development program whilst Indonesia is
trying to recover from the economic
Fallout of the pandemic and speak now to
our correspondent Florence Louis she
joins us live from BOGO in Indonesia
give us a bit more about the
significance of this visit and what's on
the agenda
oh
well the Iranian president before he
left for Jakarta spoke to reporters in
Tehran and he said this visit is about
deepening ties between the two countries
now these two countries have had
diplomatic relations since 1950 that's
five years after Indonesia gained
independence and this is about deepening
not just trade ties and economic ties
but also discussion on politics and
culture now the trade the Iranian
delegation is quite big it consists of
the foreign minister the oil Minister
the minister of information and
Communications as well as the vice
president of Science and Technology now
the last visit by an Iranian president
was in 2015 that's when President Hassan
Rouhani visited Jakarta for an Asia
Africa conference and a year later
president Joko Widodo visited Iran in
2016. now Iran said that this meeting
while it's the focus will be on trade
and economy it's also the two parties
are also expected to talk about
combating islamophobia and extremism in
The Wider world now these sort of talks
have taken place
um throughout the years in bilateral
meetings and it's expected to take place
again during this meeting the two
leaders are meeting at the presidential
Palace in BOGO and that's the building
that you see behind me this is Trade
Agreement Florence is expecting to be
finalized what's it actually involve
foreign
that's right so this Trade Agreement is
going to be called the Iran preferential
Trade Agreement from what we understand
it's taken at least seven rounds of
negotiations now Iran is an Indonesia's
biggest trade partner trade between the
two countries amounted to more than 250
million dollars but that doesn't put
Iran even in the top 20 of trade
partners for Indonesia but what to the
two countries are hoping is that this
Trade Agreement will give each other
greater access to the others markets now
for Iran that would be greater access to
the southeast Asia and the asia-pacific
market and for Indonesia greater access
to the Middle East Market now this
agreement from what we understand is
going to remove tariffs from at least
230 items over a wide range of things
from food to Pharmaceuticals to textiles
okay Florence Louis brings the leaders
they're on their own in president's
visit to Indonesia